love a friend
remembering that he can become an enemy
and hate an enemy
remembering that he can become a friend
never discuss money with people who have
much more or much less than you
save your children's tears so they can
shed them on your grave
smile a lot
it costs nothing
and is beyond price
buy not what you need
but what is necessary
in a loved one either correct the vices
or endure them
if you fix it
your partner will be better
and if you endure it
you will be better yourself
be brave
even if you're not pretend to be
no one can tell the difference
always remember that the biggest waste
you can make
is a waste of time
what you yourself will do for your
parents
expect the same from your children
don't use time or words carelessly
neither can be retrieved
[Music]
do not be contentious and quarrelsome
for such people never get out of a
beggarly state
lead a moderate and sober life if you
wish to be independent
do not bask in the presence of strangers
with your wife
and do not quarrel
the first is a sign of stupidity
the second
is a sign of Rage
remember that poverty does not come
about by diminishing wealth
but by multiplying desires
remember that a successful marriage
depends on two things
one
find the right person
and two
be the right person
do not laugh at old age
you are coming closer to it
if you intend to consult someone about
your problems
look first at how this person manages
his own problems
don't spread yourself too thin
learn to say no politely
and quickly
[Music]
live as you can
if you cannot live as you want
be careful with a joke
you may be misunderstood
no matter how much you want
but the more you have the more people
will envy you
let the person speak freely if you want
to hear the truth
take care of your reputation
it's your most valuable asset
the patient should not hide his illness
from the doctor and the poor man
cover his poverty in front of his
friends
judge your success by the degree that
you're enjoying peace health and love
be happy with what you have
but strive for the best
do nothing for money
let profit take care of profit
do not slander your neighbor so you
won't hear something that yourself will
not rejoice at
discipline yourself to save money
it's essential to success
while getting ready to do something
never talk about it
if you fail
people will laugh
if there is still something to be done
then consider that nothing has been done
yet
don't forget that very often the best
medicine is to live on without it
you won't find the kind of love that
your parents had for you anywhere
if something goes wrong
do the opposite
never underestimate your power to change
yourself
and never overestimate your power to
change others
if you want a woman to keep loving
herself
try to install in her the idea that you
are in awe of her beauty
do not answer a fool by his folly
lest you become like him
if you can't change the way you live
no one and nothing can help you
[Music]
don't reach out to a person or you'll
scare him away
make it so that the one that you want to
attract will reach out to you
take it by persuasion
not by force
one should not pursue Victory if the
benefits it brings are to be gained by
means of lowliness and crime
as we put life on hold
it
passes
be smart
choose a woman who will be grateful for
it
be smart choose a woman who didn't have
a man for long
she has found Harmony in herself
you don't have to rush into marriage
before you're 30.
but you don't have to delay after you're
30 either
don't choose as your friend the one who
does not live in harmony with his wife
in life hide your misfortunes
lest you make your enemies happy
get up from the table slightly hungry
and you will always be healthy
two Kingston youth education should be
avoided
too much austerity
and too much sweetness